(light and bouncy orchestral string music)
- [Narrator] About the
size of a house cat,
this wily little creature
is the smallest fox found in the U.S.
But even at five pounds, they
are the largest land mammal
on the Channel Islands off
the coast of California.
This is the island fox.
Island foxes are descendants
of mainland gray foxes,
but have grown smaller
over thousands of years
to adapt to the limited
resources of their island homes.
In recent years,
a chain of events caused
these little foxes
to be federally listed as endangered.
Bald eagles once lived
harmoniously with the island fox,
never considering them as food.
But then,
the less forgiving golden eagles arrived
in the Channel Islands,
and began preying upon the island fox,
hunting them to near extinction.
But through a recovery program,
the golden eagles were relocated
and the island fox population
is on the rise again.
This is the island fox.